[Music]
I've been known to miss a red
flag I've been known to put my lover on
a pedestal in the end those things just
don't
last and it's time I take my rose color
glasses off I already know tell me the I
like me life Tak me for right I already
know your I can play your right don't
you know I could do this dance all night
ooh what you
doing don't know who you think that
you're confusing I be like ooh it's
amusing you think I'm going to fall for
[Music]
was a time when that sh might have
worked was a time when I just threw a
match and let it burn now I'm grown I
know what I deserve I still like that
the lessons I already learn I already
know me I
like me life taking me for a right I
already know your you can play your CS
right don't you know I could do this
dance all
night what you
doing don't know who you think that
you're confusing I be like ooh it's
amusing you think I'm going to for an
[Music]
illusion I really like the way you
moving yeah I just want to dance with
the
illusion yeah I just want to dance with
yeah I just want to dance I dance
[Music]
what you
doing don't know who you think that
you're confusing I be like o it's
amusing you think I'm going to fall for
in I
do what you
doing don't know who you think that
you're confusing I be like o it's musing
you think I'm going
for hey there friends just want to give
you a quick shout out to my friend
Mufasa here for doing the camera work on
this one it has been way too long since
we've worked together I know School
year's over school year's over hell yeah
um muasa where can the good people find
you online y can find me on Instagram
and YouTube at fansa outstanding dude
thanks again so much yours yeah hey
there friends I hope you enjoyed that
marvelous flow session I think those are
some of the prettiest trails that I have
ever captured in all my years of doing
this and if You' like to make some
Trails yourself like that you can grab a
set of those pop and flow poy that I was
using in this video by heading on over
to the flow toys website at flowtoys.com
and using the promo code drexfactor
72024 at checkout once again that is
drexfactor
72024 that will get you a discount and
even better than that it helps out the
channel so everybody wins thank you so
much to flow toys for sponsoring this
video and giving me an excuse to go out
and play around with uh shooting really
cool trails in and around DC and
speaking of thank yous I owe thank yous
to the Friends of the channel That is uh
big thanks to dark Monk flow fests flow
toys pyroar light toys and Ultra poy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- bus friend of the
channel Becca Becken thank you so much
for supporting my channel my work and my
mission uh finally this video would not
be possible without the amazing support
of those of you who support me on
patreon in particular I'd love to give a
shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now thank you
y'all Rock uh and if you out there
watching are not currently a patreon
supporter but you'd like to become one
easily done head on over to patreon at
patreon.com drexfactor pooy and sign up
there you can get access to a whole host
of awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you and if
you'd like to check out some of my other
flow videos I will link to a playlist of
those down in the description as well as
up on screen thanks so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow yourself
today and I will see you the new video
very very soon take care now peace